the red carpet rolled out for boris
johnson at the presidential palace in
new delhi
[Music]
a home from home
[Music]
this visit twice delayed because of
covid but a welcome like this makes it
worth the wait
[Music]
still struggling to shake off the perils
of partygate you can see why he'd rather
be here than at home
a joyful
reception i wouldn't get that
necessarily everywhere
in the world
and today a post-brexit trade deal with
india his priority pm's modi and johnson
keen to pick up the pace
we have decided to make all efforts to
conclude the fta by the end of the year
we're telling our negotiators
get it done by diwali
in october
something else you want done is party
gate
but really no avoiding it that eye roll
when it was raised at the press
conference this a man uncomfortable and
fairly fed up but it's a stain he can't
shift
something else hard to shift was prime
minister modi on his refusal to condemn
russia over ukraine but boris johnson
realistic he's intervened several times
with uh with vladimir putin really to
ask him what you know what on earth he
thinks he's doing
and where he thinks this is going
and what the indians want is is peace
and they want uh the russians out and uh
i
totally agree with that
but the pm also cleared that this has so
much left to run with suggestions of a
protracted war that could last another
year or more
that is a realistic possibility yeah of
course
putin has a a huge army uh he has a very
difficult political position because
he's made a catastrophic blunder he has
the the only option he now has really is
to continue to try to use his of his
appalling grinding approach driven led
by uh by artillery uh trying to grind
the ukrainians down
this is not the trip the prime minister
intended or hoped for party gate woes
following him 4 000 miles across the
globe but he's determined to try to stay
in number 10 and today use the stage in
delhi to shift attention back to an area
where he has impressed his party and the
public his leadership over ukraine
announcing the government will reopen
its embassy in kiev next week and send
tanks to assist in poland
today like yesterday too spent paying
tributes to mahatma gandhi one of
india's most revered leaders
now this leader who won the biggest
conservative majority since margaret
thatcher left questioning whether he's
in the process of throwing it all away
beth rigby sky news in new delhi